just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just kidding news is the man of
smart people the people of just kidding
news careful boys they are very smart
just kidding news the number one forcast
in the
[Music]
world a 50-year-old man from Lithuania
was recently arrested in Spain after
allegedly faking heart attacks at
several restaurants in order to avoid
paying the bill that's kind of saw that
I love it oh he would finish everything
and then he
go the carbonara so this is apparently
he EA that dessert oh wait oh I actually
feel better can I get dessert please oh
no oh but what happens when he goes to
the hospital and they're like you don't
have a heart attack it's like why do you
have strawberry cheesecake all over your
mouth W up in ambulance ambulance it
just takes off that Beck most elaborate
like d ever so so apparently he tried
this scam at least 20 times Dam it
worked 20 times is pretty crazy
apparently uh he's became locally known
as
gasta he gets a nickname from this he
has a nickname he ordered most recently
he ordered a seafood paa and two
whiskies at the el Buen coma restaurant
taparia and late September and had a
bill of only
$36.80 right the man attempts to leave
without paying but the restaurant staff
stopped him and noted how he still
needed to pay the bill so the scammer
became visibly upset and said he was
going to get the money from his hotel
room and when the staff refused to let
him leave without paying he dramatically
threw himself onto the ground and
pretended to have a heart attack oh no
that's the problem yeah you can't do it
as your dude he has to do what I did
finish your food and then out of nowhere
oh I need the help you know think it's
more convincing to let the upsetness the
argumentative nature of that moment like
trigger you pressure going up and then
he's like versus just eating something
and then like falling over I think you
got to do it right after the meal right
after the me have to I think that's the
way to do it or or don't do it is
$36 no dude you got to do if I have to
fake a heart attack for a $36 bill yeah
but yeah 20 times though 20 times 36 you
know it starts to add up or go to the
bathroom and climb out the window maybe
that might be better but Spanish windows
are get better at it I know yeah it
sounds like he got worse I think you
mastered the technique I think after
he's done it seven times he's probably
like I'm good a slip and fall might be
good he might actually hurt something
though he's 50 that's why you got to
train with Jeremy and learn how to
[__] break fall dude I saw Insurance
sliping Fall just fall the ground I saw
Insurance slip and fall recently a dude
he went to a soda fountain and then he
got a liquid and he spilled it on the
ground and he looked around and he went
oh and he fell on the ground you saw the
whole thing from the beginning yeah they
he was just recording I mean it was a
what do you call it like a camera just
recording the cafeteria and then he was
just W looking around no one was there
he just did everything he got the
liquids out it's like a little Grandpa
too he's trying to get paid I saw one
guy I was walking to my car and there
was a big old truck making a right turn
and it was it was going really slow but
a guy was crossing the street and the
guy threw himself into the car and he
had a stack of papers on him like I
think on purpose and he hit and he flew
and he fell off the car and he threw the
papers in the air and was like oh God
through the paper he was like oh [__]
he's like oh my God and the guy and the
guy gets out the car and he knew he's
like dude I didn't hit you and he's like
yeah you did he's like oh my God he was
really selling it and I was like I
better get out of here before I'm a
witness have you seen the the Chinese
ladies fight no so like they they when
they try to like get each other on like
a lawsuit and [__] like they'll be like
arguing [__] right and then I saw one
lady going like this and then the lady
that they that she pushed she was like
oh [__] like a basketball fall and then
she fell on the ground and she's all
like oh I'm so [__] up and then the
other lady she that pushed her she goes
oh [__] and she fell to and then they
were recording the whole fight and the
whole crowd was cracking the [__] up in
China too so everybody was
laughing well not fooled the staff
called the police instead of an
ambulance and the man was recognized by
the local authorities the restaurant
said that the man doesn't speak Spanish
very well although he does seem to
understand it and His Image he's had it
again yeah his image had reportedly been
shared among many areas uh that the uh
from like different restaurants and
stuff to try and stop him from striking
again so he's not a local isn't isn't
his image I think I saw the picture it
looks like he's doing it in the image
like like he's
going he's holding his chest did he have
his face I feel like there's a picture
of it no no not on this one sorry for
ruining my article so so he's like a
immigrant or something he's not from
Lithuania he's like a fat bald white guy
do you ever do that in your fights you
play POS like I do it in practice Yeah
like you but then the the other part
where I actually do something usually
never happens though it's like I put
myself too bad of a spot where I'm like
[__] I remember one time I was in a
tournament where I was like dude tourn
was cocky tournament sorry bilingual
this guy this guy he took my back in the
tournament and it's a very if someone
takes your back it's almost [__]
you're dead right and in my head I was
like yeah put a gun in my mouth it's
either you me pal [__] I knew this was
going to happen oh [__] sorry oh [__]
but the guy takes my back and I'm like
check this out dude in my head I was
like I'm really good at Escaping The
Backs I was like I got you right where I
want you bud and then I'm like it gets
Tighter and Tighter and Tighter and
Tighter and I'm
like so I'm going to that are there
any are there any actual like fell into
my trap I see in real fighting dude you
are wiml manm dude I got my squeaky
shoes an actual like uh I'm about to
make you commit a murder is there any
benefit to playing posum in any mode
some guys do it yeah D le how do do
derck Lewis do yeah derck Lewis does
that and he knock oh before a strike
well in a sporting like event in a
sporting you would think like like
you're like and the other guy is just so
like wants to win so bad so that's why
people sto rushing in like people stop
doing the Chuck withell because people
like Jerick Lewis will be like and then
as you come in there was one out of a it
was out of a movie I think it was in
like Strike Force or yeah I think Delta
Force I think yeah Delta Delta Force and
a guy gets hit in the stomach yeah and
he's he's really hurt and he's like oh
[__] and the guy runs to try to knock
him out and then he just throws a right
hand a left hand Ko's the guy stiff and
then beats him so it's like sometime but
he and then he falls to the ground like
a [__] my stomach hurts so you end up
winning the fight cuz he KO the he koed
the guy like cold but and then sometimes
you'll see a guy where he'll get hit and
then fake posum right and then the ref
will stop it oh so it kind of didn't
work out in his favor he was too good at
it you know what I mean so so you should
tell the ref first huh yeah tell the ref
I'm going fake
it it's not real three I'm a
fake that's so about Jiu-Jitsu
specifically are there like good posa
moves for that well I tried doing that I
don't think it's a good
strategy I think you have to do whatever
your first plan was you got to do like
the subtle ones like like like uh you
know everybody's always playing the grip
game like sometimes you want them you
need to engage right so sometimes you
just be like you give them something to
grip I mean it's never that obvious you
just pretend you're going first grip so
they grab you cuz then once they grab
you you just you bait them two to one
and then you just bait them in whatever
grip that's why you guys you see
Jiu-Jitsu guy just sit on the butt all
the time they go I'm not giving you
anything okay come cuz like there's no
winner of Jiu-Jitsu until you guys do
the Jiu-Jitsu but if you guys are like
this the whole time so sometimes you're
just like all right here take that's why
they're like this dang come on baby
let's your doom brother yeah life over
brother nor your Technique that you like
to play no no Nick's technique is this
oh yeah take my back kind of but like as
a joke but also serious kind of true
it's kind of my thing rolling V bars and
[__] yeah so like in tournaments my
coach would be like hey pull guard
meaning sit to your butt and play your
play your offense right but I like to
wrestle usually but this last tournament
I did the one I lost from a year ago so
don't do this anymore yeah don't do this
Co Joe was like Hey pull guard and I'm
like I got this [__] but I've never
pulled guard in a tournament before it
was my first time doing it and the video
I try to do it and I fall and I slip and
I'm like a [__] but it was fine you fall
in slip yeah I fall in slip and you know
it choked you out again no I I actually
won that match that was the only match I
won that day you got
lucky ban won the match but he lost the
tournament
tournament do you do noie um yeah I have
I usually do no do you wear just a tight
tight underwear and grease your whole
body you sound excited why you biting
your lip dude cuz he's got an answer in
mind want no I don't I usually I've worn
tights before you know it's it's kind of
standard practice cuz that would be a
good technique is Vaseline the [__] out
of yourself so you're so slippery check
you now how slippery you are yeah they
make sure you're [__] dry and [__] I
just put some like in my mouth so as
we're
fighting you go just oil it's like an
oil can try to grab my wrist and like
and it's a I try to do the drunk and
master thing where if I'm losing a match
I'll try to drink some alcohol and see
if that works oh but that doesn't
work I've never seen a drunken master
style
Jiu-Jitsu they that would be interesting
that' be sick as [__] if they had like
those types of themes like it was Crane
style yeah like in a fight scene there's
a high tournament high rollers everyone
blazes you have to hit like a blunt or
something everyone rolls it's called
high rollers high rollers it's a pretty
big tournament like the weed the weed
the weed and Jiu-Jitsu scene is actually
very like this sometimes if you roll
high it's kind of tight I like jiujitsu
but then the other side like cuz the top
guys are in it cuz you know sometimes
when you SM when you smoke you feel
really loose and you feel like oh I
could do I CU drunk drunk would be not a
good man on each other killing each
other yeah that's bad like I wouldn't be
surprised if Eddie Bravo and Joe Rogan
only rolled High those two yeah how
about on
shrooms would be cool I think how about
on DMT I don't know about DMT iwka
tournament how about on
cra I've ever done eight months on
crack then I'll be really good maximum
strung out I actually think meth might
be the right drug for uh MMA I don't
know about that you get that yeah meth M
probably yeah meth would be up there
yeah MMA MMA Aderall might be good might
be kind of fire actually you might be
sweating balls though yeah is meth kind
of how about just 3 days no sleep and
then just full on fire every how anger
you know just pure R doesn't work I
tried doing that it doesn't work it
makes you like worse it makes you it
makes you about to cry you feel like
you're going to cry all the time yeah
anger oh look that's the end of the
[Music]
video